this week we're talking about computing
inside a container around the globe and
across the stars welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news if you're already building
an app with containers you know there's
usually more than just your code running
Google clouds kubernetes apps gives you
a simple integrated way to incorporate
open source and commercial offerings
into your environment this means that
you can deploy your app faster thanks to
pre-built deployment templates default
configurations and support for popular
packaging formats like helm charts build
your container once and deploy your full
app anywhere with kubernetes apps our
google cloud osaka region is now live
and ready for business it's our second
in japan 7th and asia-pacific and 20th
region overall and the benefits aren't
limited to just osaka a second region in
japan means lower latency and higher
availability for existing users in tokyo
read more about how this is helping
businesses and see which regions we've
got coming up next on the blog bigquery
is great for analyzing big data and it's
hard to find bigger data than astronomy
datasets big queries GIS tools aren't
just limited to earth as you can read
about in the blog post from dr. ross
thompson Google cloud solution architect
Ross talks about how these astronomy
datasets can be analyzed and how big
queries built-in tools help make it
possible to query the Stars this week is
Cube Khan and if you're there come check
out all the Googlers talking about
kubernetes if you couldn't make it don't
worry because we'll have lots of video
content and write-ups after the event
you can also stay informed with the
kubernetes podcast a weekly chat about
all things kubernetes last week they
talked about what an 'those can do for
your operations teams so make sure to
tune in if you want to read more about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link have any thoughts or
ideas leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you